i understand that it was probably
daunting to take on these women these
three enigmatic women and their places
in history but was it fear or what was
the emotion when you first said yeah i'm
gonna do this after i said are you sure
you've got the right person as a five
foot three year old eleanor right
it's such an extraordinary offer to get
to say no to somebody like eleanor it's
one of those jobs where you almost have
to say yes before you think about it too
much because if you think too much then
you might actually say no out of fear i
owe the same question to you absolutely
terrifying but with michelle obama it's
like everyone has ownership over
michelle obama i mean her book came out
it was like a best sellers list everyone
knows what she looks like what she
sounds like what her hair looks you know
so
for me
i like taking creative license i don't
like to be sort of put in a box i'm like
oh my god what did i do
i didn't want to do what jillian just
said like say yes first
and then realize oh my god well that's
what i did i said yes and i was
terrified but more terrified because i'm
afraid of what she will think in four
years i don't want to look back and
think what did i become living in that
house is it an advantage or disadvantage
because you do know her there's a sister
bond there for me so it's a girl code
it's like i gotta make the sister look
good it's all those things that you
don't think about when you're an actor
same question to you michelle were you
like jillian said yes first and thought
about it later not only did i say yes
first
i got a message that suzanne bear wanted
to speak to me that she had a project
but she wanted to speak to me first and
all she said was we're doing a show
about the first ladies and i'd like you
to play betty ford i said i'm in i never
do that i mean i torture myself over
every decision i make of course i knew
very little about betty like most people
which was one of the big attractions
once i realized the scope of his
character
it was terrifying yeah it was it was
terrifying and then there is the
pressure of oh the family you know that
right you just don't want to let anyone
down it is my great honor to introduce
to you
the first lady of the united states
oh still got it never lost it
the first lady
has to be a special kind of woman when
you were digging deep into these women
was there something that just leaped out
and grabbed you about them the thing
that impressed you most i think how
outspoken she was i was so struck by her
intense need to be honest and
transparent and do what was right she
had such a sense of integrity for
herself and her family just the personal
who they are when the doors are closed
and they have to deal with all the bull
crap that they have to navigate and then
how it sort of um settles and how it
affects the dynamics of their
relationships what it further uh led me
to is the power
of the historian
the power of the people who can write
history down
and what they miss
they don't grab that conversation that
you know the first lady had with her
husband saying you know what that law
that you're about to sign i think i
completely disagree with it i think you
need to change it a b and c you don't
get the mess you don't get the
contradictions i wonder for you jillian
same thing then you have eleanor
roosevelt who was pushing teddy
roosevelt like no no no no no this is
what we're going to do eleanor had such
a voice before franklin was in office
and continued to build on that voice but
i think that on the one hand what
surprised me about her was despite you
know we know so much about how
powerful what she was how much work she
did for civil rights we don't know is
actually how
low her self-esteem was how she suffered
from slight depression how she had so
much self-doubt because of her childhood
how much grief she had in her life
between her husband's devastating affair
and also the death of her parents and
despite the fact that internally at many
points in her life she had great great
doubt that she continued
to
speak out and to represent the things
that she believed in i was quite moved
and shocked by that suzanne and kathy
what throughout this process was the
most challenging to put this kind of
anthology together of these women the
most tricky thing i think was really
honoring these women you read everything
about them and you are so impressed and
kind of taken and seduced and kind of
feels their pain and their struggles and
you don't want to let them down and i
think that the big thing was how do you
describe 110 years and how do you kind
of honor all what they've done and who
they are in their kind of crazy
life and trajectory and not kind of let
them down in any way and still be
entertaining and fun and history hasn't
focused on the women and so there was
this huge sort of sense of how do we
reveal them in a certain way for the
first time less so in some ways with
michelle obama although she kept it very
close to the vest you know what was
really going on absolutely she certainly
did but for all of them you know how do
we shift that lens you know and see what
it was really like to be there from the
female point of view for the families
and like introduce a different way of
looking at these events in history from
behind the scenes we said we had this
huge sense of responsibility to do that
right you know to put the right foot in
front of ourselves and and show them did
you send to the families did you send to
mrs obama in the episodes have you
gotten anything back
we were waiting for the response i know
this the last time we spoke to mrs obama
and asked her she said viola davis is
the greatest you said it i mean you know
i i feel that i'm not worthy okay
i wish i could be better to live up to
the character that biola has to play um
but it is you know it's it's exciting
and anything viola does she does it with
passion and vigor and i know she will do
uh no less for this role
what do you think the best lesson that
we can all learn from the lives of these
women the power of being honest and the
power of female leadership
i mean there's tremendous power in being
totally transparent
and honest about subject matters and
about things
that people are terrified to unleash i
mean and betty ford realized when she
was honest with the american people
about her breast cancer which
none of them wanted her to do they were
terrified of it and what she saw was the
response that she got from people and
how much it meant to people and how her
popularity just
zoomed and she saw the power in that and
she never forgot it and she really
started to utilize that
in her role as first lady for me it's
the power of compassion one of the
things that we've learned in the last
two years is either we move forward
together or we
don't move forward at all absolutely and
i think that with bipartisanship i think
that with policies that have been put in
place
oftentimes they benefit just one sect of
people and every administration is
trying to
fix or reset
what the administration before did
when really the ideals and the ethos of
this country is life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness for all
and we continue to miss that it is
further emphasized i mean for me you
know in doing the research with michelle
obama barack because we were the first
black family yeah and so everything in
the emphasize the war on drugs nutrition
all of that and how it is defined by the
white community by the rich community by
the black community it's just always a
hodgepodge and at some point i don't
think it's probably going to happen in
my lifetime i just wanted to i want it
to be right i feel like that was
michelle obama's big thing too eleanor
was in the white house at the beginning
of the new deal she was part of that she
was also asked to join the united
nations and she helped to to pen the
declaration of human rights so at the
beginning of her political career and at
the end of her political career she was
helping to or at least attempting to
manifest exactly and precisely what
beulah is talking about right now in
terms of all for one and one for all not
just within america but universally so
learning from eleanor and the focuses
that both she and franklin in being in
office what ended up being 12 years and
what they attempted to do at that time
is kind of what this country needs right
now more than pretty much anything else
suzanne and kathy take us home well you
know eleanor she set it all in motion
you know she was the first modern first
lady as you know jillian was saying and
she really turned the necessary wheels
to begin
anti-racism and women's rights and
everything that leads towards what biola
was saying which is you know a country
of one where we're all together and i
think that's if anything the show can
you know reveal um the complexity of all
these years of history how much these
women and you know shared in terms of
their complete commitment to help
american people and to bring their own
values from their families the biggest
takeaway is the fact that yes highly
influential incredibly
focused on what the the position enabled
them to do in terms of
social
cultural changes but also human beings
with real lives and the understanding
for everybody watching it that life
really consists of those two entities
and that one impacts the other hugely
that the private lives actually impact
how the policy of a country or even
the world functions
i think that's probably the biggest
takeaway and also the most sort of
rewarding